amerika ein land des ungesunden hessens
der dicken menschen und der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten
das bin ich ich bin nach amerika
geflogen
zum central park grandcentral keine
ahnung wo gefahren in dem haus aus der u
bahn station
niemand einfach so ein kartenhaus also
das hat nicht sogar das wetter darum ist
das empire state building glaube ich
ganz spitze sind einfach in den wolken
das sieht so heftig aus dieser stadt ist
wie willst du das bisher mit einem wort
beschreiben
von der platte ich habe mir ein
wege
auf die ganz normal geholt hier den
brink ich auch immer noch und ich werde
jetzt mit sönke zusammen zudem telekom
laden laufen beide irgendwie internet
benötigen und und wir uns irgendwie was
anschauen wollen aber das nicht geht
oder internet nichts finden so
freundlich war telekom laden und hab mir
ein 3 gb datenvolumen denken gekauft und
video ich bin grad am schatten
wollte das sieht einfach aus wie die gta
garage hier mit dieser dreh platz
wir sind gerade in der new yorker
spontan reingegangen
reger schönen auto alles riesig ich weiß
nicht bisher nicht so richtig prunkvoll
alle zu lieblich größer in deutschland
größer
größere blätter liga
ja
wir sind jetzt gerade am die heiße
gewusst dass gerade wie das alles bringt
ist quasi einfach so ein sample pack
aber mitten in der city ich meine nicht
euch das damals da hinten die ganzen
hochhäuser hier überall aber hier ist
halt einfach so eine kleine wiese so ein
kleiner park richtig schön
das ist so typisch amerika einfach so
skisports naturally play wie viel zucker
da wohl drin fünften oder sechsten immer
mit
gerade dem richtung
sagen darf
wieder bis freunde das ist als jack wird
uns jetzt ein bisschen herum in dem
ganzen studio wo wir sind
geholfen
sieg im 47
komplett elektrisch
ich wollte da nicht film wo wir mit
patrick geredet haben weil wir die ganze
zeit über das projekt wohl rammarbeiten
gelagert haben und es ist so unfassbar
ich finde es cool bleibt wieder machen
spannend spannend also mal schauen was
die zukunft bringt die werden das ganze
veröffentlichen weiß ich nicht
irgendwann ende des sommers oder so so
viel davon noch kommunizieren es wird
richtig hammer ich hab doch nichts
gefilmt ich werde euch jetzt mal 111
gemacht haben nämlich auch instagram
hochgeladen aber sonst gehen wir jetzt
zu dem londoner pisa landingpage
teilweise den flugsteig und da werden
wir schon wieder die pizza schmeckt
eigentlich dafür dass sie ein dollar
kostet hpc latif günstig war war sie
eigentlich ganz gut unterwegs sind jetzt
auf dem weg zum central park weil ein
mitarbeiter
deswegen laufen jetzt im central park
richtig
stracke das wetter ist nicht mehr so
nahles es ist ein bisschen regnen
um solche muss wissen wie sonst was wir
jetzt gerade durch den central park
sorry falls ich ein bisschen verpeilt
aussehe oder total fertig ich bin jetzt
seit was weiß ich wie viele stunden war
und die cafés vor allem wir haben es ja
halt gerade erst mal 16 uhr oder 15 uhr
vielleicht gerade mal und deswegen sind
gerade im central park
einfach mal durch zeigt dass hier
aussieht ist halt einfach wirklich ein
normaler park man sieht einfach dass es
kein normal generierter park sondern
dass das einfach hier so nahezu alles
einfach angelegt wurde
und da hinten ist halt auch schon wieder
die downtown aber wir laufen jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal zu den nächsten
toiletten die wir irgendwo sehen können
jetzt ist es schon so krass mit synthes
problem dass er einfach weiterläuft typ
hat eine sehr schwache blase
freundlich grad im central park also ist
ja kein meister ausblick oder da hinten
ist die skyliners liegt auf dem video
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so krass
ganzen heute sind einfach nur viel höher
aber der nebel schneidet das ich komme
gar nicht auf klar auf diese stadt das
ist unfassbar
wir haben wir sind auf unserem weg zu
der bahnstation in irgendeinem kino
einen film schauen wir uns allen kinos
freunde hier ist das national history
museum hier wurde nachts im museum und
suggeriert die welt könnte daran
erinnern hier sind dann die alle lang
gefahren und so als monster ausgebrochen
sind hätte den film hat den schon mal
gesehen
gerade für catering lincoln
gewinnt gerade auf dem weg zum kino und
laufen hier gerade durch nicht strasberg
in new york wo alles so zitiert aus dem
ganzen kamera von sony häuser hat man
sieht halt einfach das teuer ist aber
sieht es richtig gut aus also wenn ich
hier wohnen würde dann hier definitiv da
hinten ist der central park direkt wo
die straße ist und hier sind halt so
überall so richtig neiße häuser so
belgisch mäßig elend war aufgrund des
schlechten wetters haben wir uns dafür
entschieden dass wir uns direkt world
anschauen
im kino hier direkt am
central park von dollar dafür bezahlt
das kostet die kinos sind alle nachnamen
alle haben alle im namen ist so 1b oder
sondern da hin und her ist es loewe oder
irgendwie so da ist irgendein teilnahme
da wir müssen in kings und wir sehen uns
jurassic park dinosaurier film und der
war richtig gute freunde von mir meint
das denn nicht so geil seiten und die
animation ganz gut aber ich kann den
film zu hammer und jetzt geht man
einfach hier raus und sieht da hinten
die skyline dahinten das ist da oben
noch im nebel verschwunden hier sind
wieder richtige hochhäuser da ist der
apple stores und konnte jetzt halt noch
weiter das ist einfach diese stadt ist
unfassbar wir können es immer noch nicht
fassen einfach hier zu sein man fühlt
sich halt direkt als wenn man so quasi
so aus im film wigan und weil es wieder
ins am 9
new york ich kann es nicht beschreiben
werde
so freunde findet wieder in der nähe von
unserem haus stellt und wir werden jetzt
noch im stall in dem trost restore gehen
und uns irgendwie 23 flaschen wasser
kaufen ich bin irgendwie so droht weil
wir schon seit 27
seit 38 stunden oder so aber ich schon
seit 13 stunden